[Music]
here's what i'm always going to give you
i'm always going to give you the hard
path on the short term
because it is the easy path in the long
term i'm never going to give you the
easy path in the short term because it's
always the hard path in the long term
easy path for her in the short term is
go buy a nicer house
but she's stuck in the debt her budget's
even tighter she's going to struggle to
be able to build wealth and find money
to save and invest for her kids college
and for their retirement investing and
be able to get the house paid off and
sally may kicked out and the other rest
of that debt kicked out that's what
normal people do they buy whatever they
want whenever they want it like they're
in congress
and normal
normal finances in america suck you
don't want to be normal
it's awful
and so what you want to be is unusual
you want to be weird so one of the
greatest compliments you get on this
show is if i call you weird means you're
being you're doing hard stuff to get an
easy life long term
it's always harder to work out and avoid
a doughnut
than it is to just pop donuts in your
face believe me i know i have the
ability to eat untold infant numbers of
donuts in one setting
and i have to curb that appetite but and
it's hard
but it's easier than walking around with
all the diseases of obesity right
well you know the minds this is a
mindset so
a lot of people think of
this type of rice and beans gazelle
intensity that dave that we teach as a
sacrifice and i think it's worth
shifting that mindset from thinking of
it as a sacrifice and think of it as an
investment it's a price to be paid yes i
am investing in
admission to a better life that's it and
you've got to invest in yourself so stop
thinking of oh it's drudgery and oh we
got a sacrifice and all we got is you
know okay here's if we do this this has
yield long-term yield long-term impact
long-term return on my investment not my
sacrifice but i'm investing in me and my
family our future yeah like a buddy of
mine there was a huge negative article
written about me a buddy of mine goes
like oh man i'm i'm so sorry and i said
well you know it's the price of a
mission to get to be dave ramsey
i'll pay the price it's awesome i don't
want to be somebody else i like me
life's good i got a great life and if
all that means is some idiot left-wing
journalist thinks i'm a capitalist pig
and correctly identified me as such yeah
um then uh then have at it baby that's
the price of admission to be dave that's
right let you know what's the price of
admission to be wealthy what's the price
of a mission to raise great kids what's
the price of admission to look at your
drunk friend and say you need to get off
the sauce you're screwing up your life
it's harder to have the conflict than it
is go along and buy them another round
hard
is easier
than easy
always turns out to be hard
because you're wimping you're mailing it
in
you're not paying a price